[Música]
prisión preventiva para Pedro Castillo
la justicia determinó que el
expresidente peruano deberá permanecer
detenido durante 18 meses mientras es
investigado por presunta rebelión y
conspiración además el gobierno decretó
toque de queda en 15 provincias del país
Tenemos reporte desde Lima
la Unión Europea anunció un nuevo veno
paquete de sanciones contra Rusia por la
guerra en Ucrania aunque los detalles de
estas medidas no se han revelado los
objetivos van desde gobernadores
regionales hasta legisladores ministros
de gobierno y partidos políticos
el alto comisionado de la ONU para los
Derechos Humanos denunció que sólo
durante las primeras semanas de la
guerra en Ucrania las fuerzas rusas
asesinaron a 441 civiles según esta
oficina dichas ejecuciones podrían
constituir crímenes de guerra
Hola Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en France 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz comenzamos en Perú porque el
juez del supremo ordenó 18 meses de
prisión preventiva para el expresidente
Pedro Castillo el dictamen se da en
medio de las investigaciones en contra
del ex mandatario por los presuntos
delitos de rebelión y conspiración para
ampliar esta noticia conectamos con
nuestro corresponsal en Lima Francisco
Zacarías Francisco muy buenas noches
cuéntenos Qué causales encontró la
justicia peruana para ordenar 18 meses
de prisión preventiva contra el
expresidente Castillo
Buenas noches fueron tres largas horas
de lectura de la resolución el juez Juan
Carlos checkley validó las acusaciones
de la fiscalía contra el expresidente
Pedro Castillo porque afirma que este
cometió los delitos de rebelión
conspiración abuso de autoridad delito
contra la paz pública por eso la corte
peruana le ordenó 18 meses de prisión
preventiva el juez checkley también
señaló que Pedro Castillo luego de leer
su mensaje donde ordena la disolución
del Congreso se dirigió a la embajada de
México y este eso constituye un peligro
de fuga y bloqueo al proceso y también
recordó que hora después precisamente
ese país habló sobre un eventual asilo
político contra el ex mandatario esta
corte le tocó otorgarle mejor suerte al
ex Primer Ministro Aníbal Torres porque
a él solamente se le ordenó
comparecencia con restricciones y el
pago de una pequeña multa
por otro lado el gobierno de Dina
boluarte decretó toque de queda en 15
provincias del Perú por cinco días
Francisco Qué medidas se establece la
Norma
el decreto supremo de la presidenta Dina
boluarte que establece esta medida de
emergencia ordena a los peruanos una
inmovilización social obligatoria y
señala que solamente deben mantenerse en
sus casas el horario para esta medida va
desde las seis de la tarde hasta las
cuatro de la mañana del día siguiente es
solamente estarán permitidos que puedan
salir de sus domicilios cuando trate de
abastecerse de alimentos y también la
norma se flexibiliza con algunas
actividades referentes a servicios de
salud
transporte energía servicios de agua
saneamiento entre otros hay que señalar
que previamente a esta medida que fue
anunciada por el gobierno de India
boluarte algunos colectivos sociales
denunciaron que la policía peruana
habría detenido violentamente a 50
campesinos estos organismos están
pidiendo que los defensores de los
derechos humanos y otros entes
internacionales se preocupen por estos
indígenas velen por su integridad y
también por el respeto a sus derechos
por este reporte desde Lima cambiamos de
tema porque se conoce más nombres de ex
miembros del parlamento europeo
relacionados con el escándalo de
corrupción que involucra a Qatar y ahora
también a Marruecos sobre presuntos
sobornos para influir en decisiones
políticas de la eurocámara la presidenta
del parlamento europeo Roberta menchó la
prometió reformas para recobrar la
confianza en esta institución Samuel
Salgado nos amplía
reunidos en Bruselas los líderes de los
27 miembros de la Unión Europea
condenaron lo que califican como una
injerencia en los asuntos internos del
bloque el escándalo conocido como
catergate en el que varios eurodiputados
son señalados de haber recibido sobornos
ha tachado el prestigio del parlamento
europeo su presidenta Roberta metzola
prometió reformas para recuperar la
confianza
a partir de hoy estoy elaborando un
amplio paquete de reformas para que esté
listo en el nuevo año
esto incluirá el fortalecimiento de los
sistemas de protección de denunciantes
del parlamento
la prohibición de todos los grupos de
amistad no oficiales
una revisión de la vigilancia de
nuestras reglas del Código de conducta
y una mirada completa y profunda a cómo
interactuamos con terceros países
la figura más prominente del escándalo
es la ex vicepresidenta del organismo la
griega Eva Kylie quien fue destituida de
su cargo y permanecerá bajo arresto
hasta su audiencia el 22 de diciembre
junto a Kylie tres parlamentarios más
están salpicados su pareja Francesco
georgie habría confirmado haber aceptado
regalos de Qatar buscando exonerar a
Kylie y un nuevo nombre aparece el exe
eurodiputado italiano piedra Antonio
panzeri quien habría recibido también
sobornos de Marruecos país que también
habría buscado influir en las decisiones
políticas y económicas de la Unión
Europea el parlamento europeo ya ha
tomado decisiones suspendió el acceso a
las instalaciones del hemiciclo a
representantes de Qatar así como el
debate de proyectos legislativos
relacionados con el país árabe también
fueron suspendidos los activos de los
eurodiputados mientras esclarecen los
hechos
y allí También en Bruselas los líderes
de la Unión Europea acordaron imponer El
noveno paquete de sanciones a Rusia en
medio de su guerra en Ucrania aunque aún
se desconocen los detalles los castigos
podrían recaer sobre unos 200 ciudadanos
rusos al tiempo el bloque pastor nuevas
ayudas para el país en guerra desde la
capital belga nuestra corresponsal
Esther Herrera con los detalles
los líderes de la Unión Europea acaban
la última Cumbre del año con
prácticamente todos los deberes hechos
para empezar han aprobado nuevo paquete
de sanciones se trata del noveno desde
que empezó la guerra en Ucrania en este
nuevo paquete se incluye por ejemplo la
prohibición de exportar drones a Rusia
pero también a países afines como Irán
para evitar que drones de fabricación
europea acaben atacando a Ucrania además
se engrosa la lista de personas
sancionadas se añaden 200 personas más y
así llegan a más de 2.000 personas ya en
la lista negra de la Unión Europea
también se ha conseguido Añadir una
excepción para que asegurar la
exportación de trigo y también de
fertilizantes y evitar así una mayor
hambruna en países en vías de desarrollo
no ha sido la única decisión tomada hoy
Porque además se ha dado luz verde a un
paquete de 18.000 millones de euros de
ayuda Ucrania y también la aplicación de
una ta del 15% para las multinacionales
la economía ha estado inevitablemente
marcada en esta reunión de líderes
europeos en que también se ha hablado de
la preocupación de la ley de reducción
de la inflación de Estados Unidos que
tiene las relaciones transatlánticas
verdaderamente tensionadas los líderes
han pedido la comisión europea que
proponga nuevas medidas para hacer
frente a esta ley que consideran
discriminatoria por último en medio de
la crisis energética los líderes también
han urgido a los ministros de energía
que se reúnen el próximo lunes a tener
un acuerdo sí O sí en un límite al
precio del gas
Mientras tanto en terreno ucraniano
continúan los ataques de las fuerzas
rusas según las autoridades locales de
gersón los bombardeos en el centro de la
ciudad dejaron Al menos dos personas
muertas otros seis civiles incluidos un
niño resultaron heridos en indoñez luego
de que una serie de proyectiles
alcanzaran varios puntos de la ciudad
mientras que uno de los combates más
brutales se lleva a cabo en la región de
bahamut por otro lado el alto
comisionado de la ONU para los Derechos
Humanos reveló que sólo durante las
primeras semanas de la invasión el
ejército ruso ejecutó a 441 civiles lo
que podría constituir crímenes de guerra
y dejó en claro que la cifra de
ejecuciones podría ser mucho más alta en
sam que ese es en algunos casos los
soldados rusos ejecutaron a civiles en
lugares de detención improvisados otros
fueron ejecutados sumariamente en el
lugar
luego de controles de seguridad en sus
casas patios y puertas incluso cuando la
víctima había demostrado claramente que
no era una amenaza
por ejemplo levantando las manos en el
aire
hay fuertes indicios de que las
ejecuciones sumarias documentadas en el
informe pueden constituir El crimen de
guerra de homicidio doloso
y finalizamos en Corea del Norte donde
Se realizaron pruebas de un motor de
combustible sólido de Gran propulsión
con el que según expertos el país
asiático buscaría desarrollar un nuevo
tipo de misil balístico intercontinental
de acuerdo con lo anunciado por la
agencia oficial de noticias norcoreana
la prueba demostró confiabilidad y
estuvo supervisada por el líder Kim Jong
en su afán de acelerar su programa
nuclear y de misiles Peón yang ha estado
trabajando para construir más
proyectiles de combustible sólido que
son más estables y pueden lanzarse casi
sin previo aviso ni tiempo de
preparación
hasta aquí este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]